[Música]
y es momento de nuestra revista de
prensa aquí en directo América vamos a
empezar con el tema de Italia en torno a
la polémica por la llegada de migrantes
en la bios humanitarios que se ha
disparado en los últimos días y hay
tensiones entre las autoridades del
gobierno de la ultraderechista Georgia
meloni y el capitán es de uno de los
barcos que han llegado hasta las costas
en el sur de Italia por cuenta de
quienes se pueden quedar y Quienes no en
condiciones de refugiados el saludo es
para mi compañera Marta Moya que tiene
todo el desarrollo de esta noticia Marta
Buen día para usted Buenos días Ángel la
vamos a empezar con el corriere de la
cera un periódico italiano que este
lunes titula
humanity One que es uno de estos barcos
humanitarios no saldremos del puerto hay
un duelo entre el viminale que es el
Ministerio del interior italiano y las
ong cuatro naves esperan en el sur de
Italia en catania a que más de mil
migrantes sean
reordenados en este país Mateo vía
Mendoza y el Ministerio del interior
firmó un decreto el pasado viernes en el
que decía que unos migrantes se podían
quedar y otros no los migrantes que se
pueden quedar los más vulnerables pero
este esta selección de migrantes ha
causado mucho rechazo por supuesto entre
las organizaciones humanitarias que
dicen que vulnera este derecho
internacional humanitario esta selección
de que uno Sí y otros no yo aquím Evelyn
que es el capitán de este humanity One
dice que desobedecerá desobedecerá
Perdón las órdenes del gobierno de
Georgia meloni porque vulneraria este
derecho
y vamos a cambiar de tema para hablar de
uno de los asuntos que acapara toda la
atención en Estados Unidos Perdón Ángela
Te quería comentar porque seguimos con
la prensa italiana el huffington post
dice el factor x de los migrantes melón
y se inventa el talento de los
desafortunados dice que el gobierno
italiano hace una clasificación de
vulnerabilidades y que no tiene relación
ni con las leyes internacionales ni con
la lógica sostiene este artículo del
jacinton post que estos migrantes son al
final náufragos en el mar y náufragos en
la vida y que El Ejecutivo de Georgia
meloni va a acabar eligiendo al perfecto
solicitante de asilo mientras el tiempo
empeora en el Mediterráneo ongs y el
ministro y al Ministerio del interior
deciden a que se acogen para reorganizar
a estos migrantes si el convenio de
Hamburgo al convenio de Naciones Unidas
o al convenio de Ginebra
Ahora sí Con permiso después de la
interrupción vamos Ahora sí a cambiar de
tema a Estados Unidos y como decía
entonces acapara toda la atención este
asunto de las elecciones de medio
término Ya faltan menos de 24 horas para
que abran los colegios electorales y
para que se renueve senado cámara y
algunas de las gobernaciones Cuál es el
repaso de medios sobre este tema Así es
vamos a empezar Ángela con político que
hace un análisis que dice sigue siendo
un referendo sobre ambos vaiden y Trump
finalizan los exámenes parciales camino
a las presidenciales de 2024 Y es que
tanto el presidente como el expresidente
aunque no están en estas tarjetas
electorales toda la campaña de las miter
de las elecciones de medio término a
versado sobre ellos después del asalto
al Capitolio de la derogación de
robertsus wave de la guerra en Ucrania o
del segundo impeachment fallido contra
Trump Parece que la campaña de las se
quedó como terminó la contienda
electoral en 2020 eso dice este análisis
de político al final las elecciones de
medio término serán un plebiscito sobre
la gestión de Joe biden y también para
el ex presidente Donald Trump sobre sus
investigaciones por corrupción y Bueno
sobre sus exabruptos para con la
democracia seguimos en el Washington
post porque los demócratas dicen este
artículo han mirado hacia el centro
mientras los republicanos amplían su
base en estas últimas horas de campaña
los demócratas han reforzado esos
mensajes para mirar al electorado que no
tiene un candidato definido y los
republicanos han lanzado toda su
artillería para hablar de los asuntos
más polémicos como la identidad cultural
o la cuestión racial y terminamos con un
artículo del New York Times que titula
crece la grieta entre Trump y de santis
el gobernador de Florida porque han
hecho campaña por separado
y para terminar este que usted ha
llamado el gran evento del año para
afrontar la emergencia climática la co27
que ya empezó en Egipto con sus
encuentros de alto nivel y que atrae por
supuesto todo tipo de titulares
alrededor del mundo cuéntenos algunos de
ellos así es Ángela vamos a empezar con
el Guardian que hace una exclusiva donde
dice que Estados Unidos y Reino Unido
están muy por debajo de los miles de
millones que se comprometieron a
invertir para hacer frente a la
emergencia climática esto nace de un
pacto en 2020 donde los países más ricos
se comprometieron se comprometieron
perdón a
invertir más de 1.100.000 millones de
dólares para hacer frente a la
emergencia acrimate climática sin
embargo Estados Unidos solo ha aportado
40.000 millones Perdón 7,6 millones de
los 40.000 que se había comprometido
Australia y Canadá un tercio de lo que
se había comprometido y Reino Unido tres
cuartas partes sostiene además que esta
financiación es imprescindible
para generar una confianza sobre la
acción global de todos los países
pues Marta Le agradezco por este
completo repaso y nos falta todavía un
medio nos falta todavía un medio el
global Time se china un partido muy
alineado con el partido comunista que
hace también un repaso sobre la con 27 y
sostiene que Estados Unidos y China
quebraron esas relaciones de cooperación
climática con la visita de Nancy pelosi
a Taiwán el pasado agosto es difícil que
se vuelvan a reunir de manera bilateral
en esta cop27 y que Estados Unidos es un
socio poco confiable porque si lo
republicanos ganan las elecciones
legislativas Se podrían revertir todas
estas acciones climáticas que quiere
impulsar Joe biden y terminamos con el
cartón movement porque destacamos una
viñeta muy crítica de un artista de
Países Bajos que la que vemos aquí en
pantalla no lo estamos viendo en
pantalla
bueno son los líderes reunidos en torno
a una mesa de negociación mientras Ven
por la ventana el mundo arder Bueno pues
pareció muy de fan Marta pero te
agradezco de nuevo pero de todo este
repaso de los medios en torno de estas
tres noticias con las que se despierta
este lunes el mundo el agradecimiento es
para usted y pues nos veremos mañana no
gracias Ángela Hasta mañana y es